why is confidence so attractive
why is confidence so irresistible the
idea that an individual that you come
across in the world knows a secret that
you don't they know something there's a
twinkle behind their eye and it speaks
to you that makes you feel like they
know something that you don't they're at
ease in ways that you wish you were they
have this groundedness they have this
stability they have this emotional
presence they fill the room with their
with their sense of knowing and you know
we come across these people in our lives
and we're explicitly drawn to them it
doesn't matter if it's sexual attraction
or just an amicability just somebody you
want to be friends with but the desire
to be near those that project this kind
of confidence has to do with wanting to
drink the kool-aid that they drank to
want to glimpse the supposin truth that
they've been exposed to and it could be
a false projection it could just be that
these people are simply physically
attractive and the equanimity with which
they move about the world seduces us
into thinking that they know the answers
that somehow we don't and I don't know
which is the case I don't know if they
actually know those answers or if
they're just really good at lying about
it but I've always always always been
drawn to these people and it doesn't
matter if they're you know eloquent
professors or movie stars or just you
know the coolest kid in school that
confidence that sense of knowingness
that they bring forth is something that
I've always been itching to acquire and
there's certain moments in my life
certainly when I feel - and then and
when I feel alert awake and aware - some
kind of deeper veracity some deeper
truth that fills me with joy gratitude
with grace and during these moments I
taste a sliver of that confidence but
it's not yet stabilized in my life I
still collapse back into myself with all
my fears and
season doubts and the journey continues
anyway that's those are my thoughts on
[Music]